breaking news a warning from the prime
minister that it is touch and go where
the cop 26 will secure the agreements
needed to tackle climate change his
downbeat message comes just days before
the environmental summit gets underway
in glasgow next week attended by world
leaders
it could be very very tough
this summit
and i'm very worried because it might go
it might go wrong
and we might not get the agreements that
we need and it's it's touch and go
it's very very difficult but i think it
can be done
live to westminster in our political
correspondent kate mccann less than a
week to go at kate and the prime
minister far from optimistic what has
led uh to this pessimistic tone from him
well i think there are a number of
reasons for this perhaps slight change
in tone from the prime minister who
remember just a few weeks ago was saying
it's easy to be green really talking up
the way that global leaders could make
significant changes to really help the
outcome of this climate conference i
think since then we've seen some pretty
significant global figures say they
won't be attending and that's been of
concern to the government particularly
russia and china where there are big
problems with emissions that really do
need to be curbed i think without the
buy-in of some of those those most
polluting nations it will be difficult
for the uk government to claim success
from this conference but there are also
some worries about the amount of money
the financial commitment that countries
around the world are willing to put in
and really what this conference is
actually going to be able to tangibly
achieve i think boris johnson has set
his sights very high here not just
because of course the environment is a
central policy for this government
there's been some significant
commitments from the uk government on
how to cut carbon emissions for example
but also because this is really a huge
global summit boris johnson is a leader
who's left the european union he wants
to put the uk back on the map in terms
of the center of global change this is a
real opportunity for him and so he needs
it to go well and actually this press
conference with children has been a
fascinating watch i have to say children
always ask very interesting questions
very honest and direct questions it's
also very difficult for boris johnson
not to answer them perhaps more
transparently even than he would with
some journalists so his answers have
been really worth listening to you heard
him there talking about how things are
touch and go how they might not
necessarily be as successful as he hoped
we've seen him sort of hedge his bets a
little bit before
and they run up to this conference
particularly around the g7 suggesting
that people really did need to pull up
their socks if you like and really make
some significant moves towards making
this conference a success but he's also
been talking about recycling he said we
can't recycle our way out of this
problem you can only recycle things once
or twice he actually shocked i think
he's co-hosted a little bit in the wwf
by saying that really this is not the
answer to such a global crisis emergency
he's also been talking about things like
sustainable farming and about packaging
in supermarkets he was asked whether
you could get rid of some of the plastic
wrapping for example on some of the
foods that we all buy in the supermarket
and he said that was the totally right
idea he's also been asked about what
global leaders could do to make a
difference here the prime minister said
he used to be able to cycle everywhere
he said something like those were the
days so
i think going into this conference the
government here is setting a slightly
different tone perhaps trying to manage
expectations about what cop can actually
achieve but make no mistake there will
be
lots of concern and lots of pressure now
on boris johnson and on other global
leaders he was asked that point
repeatedly by the children at this press
conference we want you to tell global
leaders to do more
he said there will be a lot of peer
pressure on them from countries that
really have stepped up to the plate the
ones that perhaps haven't and he hopes
that peer pressure will result in some
real change